the
recording seems to be
working good so let's try to start with
the with the subject of uh of the
identification and this lecture is
relatively cartoon brief overview lot of
pictures no mathematical formulas
whatsoever uh we will basically look at
how our world works at the at the moment
how it how it uh used to work and what
what changed why should we uh look at
the the subject of uh of system
identification I guess I had this slide
already uh showing you for our modeling
in process industry class but uh yeah
maybe we will dive a bit bit deeper to
it today so the first message I really
like this really like this graphic the
the first message is that our our world
is uh really accelerating the everything
is uh everything is uh happening faster
and faster so our Agricultural
Revolution which means that we stopped
we as a mankind stopped wandering around
the earth and we settled down somewhere
where we had the field with our crops
with vegetables fruits and so on uh
happened at some point and it took 8,000
years until the the Industrial
Revolution where we realized we can uh
divide the the the jobs in the in the in
the society that we can make some jobs
even somehow automated or at least
mechanized like we can use uh steam
engine we can use uh
some
um some some engines to help us in in in
in our in our world um then from the
industrial Revolution to the invention
of light bulb only only 120 years passed
between the invention of light bulb and
moonlanding there is only 90 years 20
years from moonlanding to the worldwide
web and 9ine years to the sequencing of
human genome it's completely arbitrary
these events but there are big events in
the in the in the human human history
the interesting part is that this this
is a this Gap is really short shortening
and uh we are we are speeding up in the
development and the speed up uh in the
development in the in the 20th and 21st
uh century was also observed in
something which is called more slow did
you hear about more slow
before more of Zakon in
Slovak there was a Mr Moore m is
nodding m did you hear that about mors
law I the picture
uhhuh do you remember something about
that not okay and if if you if you would
have to guess what would you guess about
how technology is advancing more and
more rapidly mhm mhm yeah and uh
concrete example is that uh Mr Moore was
a engineer in I think Bell Bell
Laboratories in in us and uh what he
observed well he did a databased
observation he took some data he took a
Time AIS and he marked several points
and these points represented the number
of uh now I have to find the correct
number what was it the number of
transistors the number of transistors on
the different uh computer process
processors or nowaday maybe we would say
on on the chips so how much basically
how much computing power does a
processor processor hold and he and he
picked the the the depicted drwn this uh
this
data and he and he found out that uh
roughly each 10 years the number of the
transistors is
doubling what does it mean if it's if
something is something is doubling what
uh what kind of growth is it is it a
linear growth quadratic growth
logarithmic growth exponential growth or
or anything else what do you think
exponential exponential right because
that's the standard uh example the first
example of the
exponential growth is uh some story
about sha in Iran or some or or a or a
Persia who was uh who was playing uh
playing chess with uh with with one one
of his uh one of his workers servants
and uh and he lost lost in the game of
chess and he he he said uh he asked the
servant what he wants for uh as a award
for for the Victory and the servant said
okay I will put one grain of rice on the
first square of the of the chessboard
then I I will then I want you to put two
grains of rice on the on the next uh
next what is it piece of a of a
chessboard and uh and then uh then then
you you will be doubling yeah so do you
have a two grains of rice on the
second what what is the what is the word
now I'm missing the word what is the
word polko in
English slot slot is good there is
something
R you place chess field
no Square yeah square is the correct one
or S sounds good so on the third Square
there are four grains of rice on the
fourth Square there are eight grains of
rice and it's doubling and once when you
reach the the end so two to the power of
64 uh grains of Rise you basically have
uh the same amount of Grace of rice
grain of rice as the number of atoms in
the univ ver or even even more than that
so it's uh it's quite quite scary and
uh how how actually does does this uh
this plot work if you if you look here
on the on the y axis it's actually not a
not a linear scale it's actually Lo
logarithmic so
[Music]
one uh one one movement one one one step
in this direction doesn't mean like
adding like 1 2 3 4 5 six doesn't mean
like uh like adding the same amount of
numbers but it's adding the the number
of powers of of 10 yeah so we can easily
see see it here the one step corresponds
to increasing the scale by 10 to the 10
to the 5 so by 100 100,000 yeah so
increase by 100,000 increase by 100,000
increase by 100,000 or change of a of a
of 100,000 here it's even even better
visible from one to 100,000 so already
this this plot is uh is is
showing if if we if we got a if we got a
straight line that's already an
exponential growth but uh this is what
uh what Mr Moore observed and uh later
with the farther farther Evolution we
actually we actually saw that this is
this uh mors law is getting even even
violated and uh we are we are seeing
even more rapid development and even
more number even higher number of
the what was it uh higher number
of ah now one for forgot the
word transistors transistors on a on a
you see that I'm not a hardware guy so
that's why I cannot remember this these
Hardware Hardware
terms uh prediction was this this graph
is from 2011 I just like the graphics
that's why I I keep on having that we
will we will reach the singularity at
some point we will Sur surpass in 2023
the computing power of a of a PC of a of
of a chip will surpass the the human
brain maybe we are somewhere somewhere
around
it um the same
Trend in slightly different numbers is
actually happening with the with the
number of data yeah that's what I was uh
trying to trying to tell you in the in
the in the beginning cheap sensors more
available sensors more reliable sensors
give rise to uh more sensing capacity we
can we can sense sends more more data we
can store more data with a with a much
smaller smaller price and uh well now we
have a problem that we need to make a
sense of data the world is extremely
extremely rich with the with the data
and now this will be Slovak and Slovak
and English combo with uh because I took
some some news uh this is maybe from
2022 where they say that the prices of
the of the breeds of dogs uh rapidly
changed during the during the covid
pandemics uh in in UK in great Great
Britain
um nice right
uh why was
this why why why did it happen that the
price PR of the dogs of the different
different breeds
increased what did I
do
better H the Dem
r i don't cannot hear or cannot
understand once again the
demand yes why did the demon
rise because I believe during the pmic
only people with doors were allowed to
go
outside exactly very good and also we
were alone stuck at our homes and we and
we wanted to have some have some friends
along exactly yeah so very very
important uh think uh the data doesn't
doesn't uh tell us uh what what happened
yeah they just uh uh they are just
sitting in some database usually it's uh
good thing to to plot them to actually
have some have some kind of overview
some statistics but uh some at least
basic statistics but uh to make sense of
out of data that's a much much harder
harder problem it's it's no nowhere sh
um what happened here so we have the
same photo from some satellite which can
actually show the nitrogen dioxide
levels in in China in January 2020 and
uh the same measurements in February
2020 the nitrogen dioxide levels are uh
much lower what
happened Factory shut down yeah Factory
shut down because of the co9 pandemic
yeah I use the covid-19 pandemic a lot
in this in this lecture because it's a
great s of the uh of the data you can
think of it as it was really uh you you
did with your flexi device the step
change in some input it was a step
change in many many inputs in the in in
the world yeah um another one we can see
a big step change also happening around
March
2020 there are uh fossil fuel prices so
some oil some NAFTA Natural Gas uh there
is even there is even even coal um so
the the the question would would be yeah
if I if I can predict what is what is
going to going to happen let's say I'm
I'm in January 2020 and I already heard
yeah there is something spreading in
China and if I if I can predict what's
going to happen with the oil prices then
I can of course adapt to that I can uh
tune tune my uh strategy of my of my
company to actually well be prepared we
need to buy more oil we need to maybe
empty our reservoirs for for oil because
the price is getting is getting down and
soon it will it will rise rise again so
I can I can make some make some money
yeah money is of course a Big Driver
hopefully it it won't won't stay won't
stay that but at the moment we are
basically there uh this is a quite nice
cartoon uh the Kyoto aquarium has a flow
chart of uh complicated romantic
relationships between their Penguins I
haven't been there but uh yeah once I'm
once I'm there I I I'll be very uh very
interested to to see how it how it works
so
um some data was tracked how the
penguins penguins uh like each other
whether they are maybe cheating on their
Partners stuff like that um and then and
then depict it um I have no idea how
they actually uh make sense of this or
how they actually use it may maybe maybe
the the people who are maintaining the
aquarium can use it such that they are
avoiding the uh the fights between like
some uh like some uh love triangles
yeah okay
this one is uh getting already already
interesting the the headline is is
basically basically enough uh Facebook
uh what was it April
2021 at some point uh decided to uh to
block the web page of a French city Bish
why was
that yeah s s sounds like sounds like
some some swear
uh what what happened what why why why
did this
happen statistically the combination of
letters in the work is mostly used in
dead way so just said it's probably also
the spare exactly exactly yeah so the
Facebook has apparently a a policy that
uh the Square words should not be uh
names of the of the websites or of the
what is it fa Facebook Facebook sites or
Facebook users and uh and uh then they
are running an algorithm because well
there are many many of the of the
websites then they are running an
algorithm which is comparing the the
square words and the and the names and
with some statistical evidence with some
probability this algorithm said okay
with more than 95%
% uh confidence I can I can claim this
this website is violating the the
rules um this one is already quite old
and I don't know whether it really
really materialized so how how can we
how can we use uh use the data uh Google
Maps is was supposed to offer the most
eological the most environmental
friendly uh route for for your for your
car once you once you were trying to
find the the route for it um did it
happen I don't know do you use Google
Maps or anything and I think it's it
still offers like the the fastest and
hard hard to say whether I can whether I
can find my uh carbon footprint uh for
this part or or or this part maybe maybe
it will happen I think it provides also
the
shortest like the lowest m yeah however
I believe it doesn't take into account
anything you go up or down yeah yeah
yeah because uh it can also you go you
go up up or down is is one option and
another option is uh is of course it it
tells you about possible or The
Happening traffic gems so that's not
ecological because then usually you end
up running your your engine in stuck in
in some in some Gem and uh not really
not really doing doing
anything I also like like this news so
this is getting uh uh quite uh quite
personal and uh the data and it's about
the data breaching of course it's it
sounds sounds funny yeah the the the
headline so if you listen to to Nickel
Beck be be aware of this of this threat
uh but it uh points to a not another
another aspect that uh data P privacy
how do we encrypt data how how can we
Cipher the data to make them uh
in inexp posable to some third parties I
cannot name any specific countries in
the world to be politically correct but
yeah you can imagine that you don't want
to share your data with with anybody but
still we are we are doing it quite
of ah my beloved uh Trend uh for for the
for the examples of uh how the how the
world uh works with data
uh there are even some some dates there
will be couple of more headlines
headlines coming and uh and you might be
even even guessing which which year is
it uh is it taken from bitcoin price uh
is over $30,000
bitcoin price could go in the long-term
Horizon to
$140,000 uh bitcoin price over
40,000 uh uh in three days the the price
is down by by
1 uh the price and this is now
chronological yeah so the value of
Bitcoin is below
$30,000 the value of Bitcoin is now up
in just seven days by by
20% uh and if you see this this the span
of this of these news that's really from
one year the the span of this news is is
just uh just one
month how to how to plot plot this so
how to visualize this data because I
mean you would agree with me that it's
quite hard to keep keep track on on this
uh on these different different
newspaper newspaper headlines so let's
try plotting it uh we are still below
here $3,000 so the the headline news
were definitely uh from from some from
some future future times uh compared to
this graph so Bitcoin I think it started
or or at least my Trend starts in 2013
already quite quite some time ago well
it had some initial Hy
uh maybe people start start to buy it
and then the then the price went down so
maybe if you are in August 2015 you
might be quite quite sad that from
$1,000 now you're now the value of your
valuable Bitcoins of your investment is
is quite down but there is no reason to
be said because if you just waited two
years look there if you if you bought
even for this price ,000 you are already
300% in plus just in four years yeah the
Investments uh take take some time
um so this is the previous graph and now
we we are extending it yeah so this is
this red line is showing where the
previous graph graph ended and we are we
are now in again quite quite a volatile
volatile period the the price of the
Bitcoin kept on kept on increasing 2017
2018 so again H what if I caught this
trend quite late and I bought the
Bitcoin for $
12,500 in just maybe half a year or or
almost a year well we are we are back
basically to the to the value where uh
about
$2,500 so again should we be sad about
about this should we should we sell our
Bitcoins probably not because it again
would would change and uh yeah then we
can again think and reason what would
happen to the people to you to to us in
different different situations uh
whether we are happy that we that we uh
bought the Bitcoin for this price and
now now the now the price is around
again above 10,000 $1,000 it's still
still a good
investment we don't need to be said at
all because yeah in 2021 and that's
that's where that's the year where the
headlines uh which I showed you uh from
the newspapers before were were coming
from it got another another big uh big
impulse now I don't don't remember what
what happened what happened that that
year I guess uh there were some
regulations
where uh got got milder so um it got uh
better acceptance with the merchants uh
in the in the in the market um good so
how will access to the market like
public yeah yeah yeah and also it's in
theic so people don't
travel a lot of time they don't have the
need for goods they usually have so they
have like exis man in the US most of the
people could like just free money they
get just check ,000 to start the economy
okay well well good and they invested
good guesses you have some Bitcoin bot I
used
to good uh so yeah where are we so this
is 2021 where did we uh moved from from
there now uh this is uh this is slightly
different Graphics but it but it shows
basically the the the same same data
this is almost end of 2021 so there is
another another another small small Peak
uh it's interesting uh I I took this um
took uh took this data from well some
some website the website offered not
only to show the the price in the linear
scale but also the logarithmic scale
similar to to what we saw with the mors
law and in the logarithmic scale if you
if you plot if you if you put it in in
into this way actually
if you if you get this get this data
from some experiment wouldn't you be
really tempted to actually put a
straight line to it and and start start
predicting whether uh whether the the
amount the price of Bitcoin in 2025 will
be where where it is now yeah
interesting interesting question but it
at least shows
that um visualizing the data in some
different con
context can show can reveal at least
some some
information uh this is the price until
2023 there was some some steep decline
but ah this is getting
already already not that not that
visible it should be until
the maybe mid 20 2024 so there was from
this decline there was again a a
recovery and the recent one so the value
here is from the basically end of the
year this is maybe from last week the
the the snapshot we got the uh us
elections that uh and all this uh all
this hype about about it uh which uh
which again skyrocketed the price and uh
if we would would go back
uh this this headline which says in the
longterm Horizon the Bitcoin should
should could climb up to
$146,000 uh if you this is in 2021 so if
you think about this for uh one two
three years uh you you cannot cannot see
this see this
going but at the at the moment well we
are we are quite quite attack attacking
that yeah uh this is not to persuade you
convince you to invest in Bitcoin I
don't invest in Bitcoin because I I
don't like the the idea um that it only
drains the resources and it has actually
no no value but uh it uh it shows that
uh there are uh different uh aspects in
in the in the data that uh will actually
cause the change of of some Trend at
some point yeah this is the US elections
somewhere here there will be a big big
jump where when Elon Musk decided to buy
uh one billion invest 1 billion dollars
in in Bitcoins that also increased the
value it's quite hard to actually find
out what happened that that caused the
caused the the trend that caused what we
what we see uh in the in in the data
values let's try a another uh another
Trend uh and now it's uh up to you to to
to guess what what is it what is it
showing uh I can reveal these are the
time units uh and okay I will I will
also reveal these are the days yeah so
day one to to to
33 uh and the value of the trend is uh
650 uh we again move in move in time and
uh we have now 100 100 days one to one
to and one and our our previous Trend uh
got got re got
reversed okay and we have another
another part so this is our previous
previous Trend yeah this reached around
around thousand whatever the the value
is and now in basically almost almost
one year we got we got this these Peaks
what would you think what where where
are this this data coming
from and you can suspect the uh the the
trends which I said that I that I liked
uh in the that I that I like to observe
for this for this lecture so one is
Bitcoin and another one is uh is some
nice nice pandemic what would you what
would you think these numbers are this
trend
is yeah Corona Co and
uh what what exactly
exactly the number of the Active covid
cases in Slovakia between March 2020
January 21st uh we had the
first first mild wave but but then uh
the the second wave uh after the after
the summer so this is September 2020 uh
hit us quite quite heavily um it's also
also interesting so very very very
similar similar Trend
um related related data uh now it shows
uh the days since since first case on
the on the horizontal axis so basically
some time and uh we have the number of
daily uh PCR cases PCR was a method of
uh testing for the for the covid uh
antigen and PCR those were those were
the those were the two and uh this is a
Matlab plot done by me so I took some
data from this uh National Center of uh
health information and uh and I plotted
it the first graph which I got is this
yellow
thing why would you think the the we can
see this uh this sharp uh spikes this
these Peaks
genius exactly exactly like like that
the the problem with uh with with the
with this data uh used to be I don't
know whether you observe the the news Al
I remember at least for the first first
year every day we were checking in in
the news how many new cases we we got
and it was always the number of new
cases was much higher on on Monday
because many of the places for testing
either didn't work on on on weekends or
the people decided to uh to spend some
time with the flu in their in their in
their home not that they were spending
uh some other time outside um um and uh
and got and they got they got tested on
on
Monday what uh what we will see also
also in this in this course is uh how to
how to reveal reveal uh this this kind
of trend so the so the blue curve here
is uh is trying to do some sort of uh
averaging uh I don't know whether you
recall it in our uh pandemic times we
were quite quite interested in 7 Days
median number of the Active cases and
then there was this uh traffic light
whether something is aof based on based
on the number of the of the active
Active cases based on the 7 Days median
yeah so this blue blue curve is is
trying trying to to do something similar
something which you might have already
seen or you will see in your Technic
means of automation class uh where when
you will do some filtering did you do
some filtration filtering okay you
already already did so this is nothing
else than just some applied applied
filtering and uh even prime minister was
using the results of this of this
filtering um what we can also also guess
uh from the from the data uh this is uh
again some covid-19 data but not from
Slovakia this time this time this time
from from Germany uh they had a well the
first wave actually similar to Slovakia
it was it was quite quite mild then the
second second wave was uh was much much
tougher and uh and then it continued so
the the top plot shows shows what shows
the number of the of the cases while the
the bottom plot shows the more said
number uh even the the N number number
of deaths so number of people people
passed away uh what can we what can we
first observe on this uh on these
pictures if we if we compare them what
would you guess
there wasn't capacity to like proper
Health Care to everybody probably okay
that's that's strong uh that strong
conclusion in the second way because if
we compare it it's like much deeper in
comparation
to you mean here yeah I I mean like if
we compare the quantity of deaths to
quantity of
cases sure well but okay but you are
making a conclusion so my conclusion is
not everybody that got covid uh dies
right right so okay um good um maybe
maybe let's uh let's see what what do
what do these two trends at least in the
beginning have have in
common the basic uh how would you call
it the the Bas basic shape is is common
yeah so these two variables these two
signals as we would uh we would call
them in uh in the cybernetics they are
showing uh what what is known as
correlation yeah they are they are they
are correlated because uh if one one
signal is increasing another signal is
is increasing is actually not at the at
the same time so we can uh we can say
this this system yeah if we are
observing this as two variables this
this this will be some some sort of a
dynamic system some some process yeah
there there was one one thing one thing
happening at the process which might
have triggered we don't know because the
correlation and causality are not the
not the same thing but the data is at
least is at least showing us that it
that it triggered uh some uh some
response at least at least qualitative
yeah okay the the numbers numbers are
are are are not the same but the thing
that is that is happening uh is is is
quite
similar uh yes and now we can now we can
go for example to to this peak
which that's kind of some some sort of a
third wave uh in
2021 which is not that pronounced in the
in the number of number of
deaths what what do you think what what
might have happened
then very very good yeah either either
it is uh it is it is vaccination yeah we
started with the vaccination well really
somewhere around here yeah February 20
21 and uh that's that's one thing
another is the some mutation of a virus
the virus might not have been that
deadly because uh it evolves and the the
variant of the of the virus was not that
that deadly and uh also uh there might
have been already some builtup
resistance in the in the population
because well people could could be
infected by the by the co multiple times
okay let's go away from from from the co
Let's uh let's talk about some other uh
data data patterns anybody recognizing
recognizes this
picture okay Patrick is nothing as well
yeah what what does the does the picture
say or what do you know know about the
story shows
yeah the the question the actual
engineering problem was uh in the in the
SEC Second World War uh what should we
do to make our to make more airplanes
come back uh come back safe or at least
come back from some from some fight from
some battle and uh What uh what this
graph shows it it actually shows a
collection of data from several several
planes uh and and it shows where the
where the plane was uh was hit and and
still still returned so now the now the
question is uh if uh we should
reinforce the parts which are which are
hit or whether we should reinforce the
parts which are which are not not hit
what does the data say what is the
Paradox in this in this
picture I know in the correlation it's
like show showing as the survival ship
as I
believe because those planes that were
hit in these places actually returned
home so the moreing force spot should be
really those that are not hit yes yes
yeah the like a very simple and and
naive thought no problem with naive
thoughts but uh like a Sentimental
thought like all these poor airplanes
they are shot here here here we should
reinforce it there but it would not not
happen not not not help because uh what
actually made the airplane to to not
return is when the engine was shut yeah
uh if if you think about it when the
pilot was
shut so that's a
that's actually exactly Adam described
it it's a survival bias we are uh or
when this uh tiny narrow narrow part was
shot so so we we need we need to uh
enforce enforce these parts so the this
is a one of the very early uh databased
uh decision decision making uh making
problems how to make sense out of data
and how to act accordingly such that we
improve proove some some
performance uh another example of the of
the data is uh well not only this
cardiogram but uh many many uh screening
techniques in the in the medicine are
producing this sort or some other sort
of uh sort of data like you would be
scanned for some tumor you would be
scanned xray for for some for some sort
of uh well not only broken bones but
problems with the teeth and yeah what
whatever you name it um many many
interesting interesting data points and
uh it's uh also growing the number of
data is growing the number of uh skilled
uh doctors who can who can read this
data is actually not growing that much
so we need to do something about it uh
that's why uh Adriana is trying to find
some uh find maybe her summer uh summer
internship in the seens healthy years
who actually uh work on on this type of
problems taking some some data or even
maybe making this uh you know this is
just the piece of paper and some ink pen
was uh was uh collecting the data so
first to digitalize this is is already
already a a big step uh and secondly to
find some trend Trends to reason what
what happened when how what is the
status of the of the patient how should
be what is the diagnosis how should we
uh Help The Help the patient what
treatment uh another sort of uh
visualization of data quite similar to
the to the plain uh example is
uh electricity
generation compared to CO2 intensity per
country so now this is taking the amount
of the electricity generated this is
interval one hour yeah so each each uh
each hour they would sample this is
France you cannot see see it well it
doesn't show our Beamer this is Germany
Poland Slovakia has not here
unfortunately Italy espia Belgium
Portugal and so on uh so each each hour
the uh El electricity Generation by the
power plants in the country is is
measured and what is also measured is
the CO2 intensity so how much CO2 is uh
emitted to the to the Atmosphere by this
by this
production
um we are
tell me what what would you what would
you have uh observed what would you have
concluded from from from this
plot there are many conclusions you
can you can
do the Polish production is the least
effective
M why is that what do you
think exactly yeah they have a lot of
coal and they have a lot of lot of coal
power plants and France on the other
uses a lot of
nuclear yeah very very very good France
is is is is quite quite interesting uh
because it it shows what it doesn't
matter how much power the country needs
it would still emit the roughly the the
same amount of the of of the CO2 yeah so
this is the efficiency or environmental
friendliness of the of the nuclear power
plant Poland is uh is basically
basically on the on the on the other
other end but well their uh electricity
generation is even much much narrower so
they are not not that flexible we we
could say yeah France is relatively
flexible uh with the with the
generation uh but yeah they are on the
high end with the environmental
friendliness uh what about Germany
Germany has also some some quite
interesting interesting Trend don't know
whether you would Spot It
mhm yes exactly so when when they have
the huh huh but how to how
to
off yes yeah this is
already
mhm yeah uh okay but uh let's not let's
now even even forget this this is this
is Germany and
[Music]
U let's let's see whether uh you may
maybe it's only me who who sees this but
whether you would you would agree that
it it sounds like there is a there is a
lot of happening along like like this uh
this uh axis yeah which would have like
what uh uh negative uh negative
derivative like uh what what what does
it what what does it actually actually
say if I need to Pro if I'm producing
relatively small amount of energy I have
quite high CO2 CO2 um emissions but if
I'm
producing atively high amount of of
energy or electricity uh then then than
my than my CO2 production CO2 emission
lower
lowers you you see a Sim similar
situation yeah okay it's it's not not
only me perfect and this is uh uh this
is quite uh uh quite controversial or or
or you or you are you are thinking at
first whether whether it makes sense but
exactly as as patri was was saying this
this is the the effect of uh of the coal
power plants running uh even uh even
when some Renewables are are not
Renewables we might mean uh the the the
solar power plant so the high amount of
the generation is actually coming dur
during the during the day during the
peaks of when there is a uh when there
is a good wind for wind turbines
uh clear day for the uh for the for the
solar solar cells so uh quite
paradoxical in the in the beginning but
uh actually can we can we can make make
sense out out of
this and uh this brings us what you will
try in your uh in your exercises uh uh
brings us to different types of the
visualization of of the data yeah so
what where we are starting is uh
we uh collected some collected some data
and even by using different plots of the
data we can we can uh already find uh
find some some insights um I picked here
four types of the of the data
visualizations that are very very uh
common uh many of them you already
already know and many of them we have
already already seen today so the time
series uh this is what uh what you have
uh been doing seeing in theory of
automatic control this is what we what
we saw here today time series just means
that whatever signal whatever Trend
whatever information data I got I
basically ploted with a with its
corresponding time step on the on the
horizontal horizontal axis if I have the
the the time stamps yeah uh for example
we will we will get back to this plot
but there are there are no no time steps
time stamps here yeah so we actually
don't don't know where when when is this
point happening when is this point
exactly exactly happening well we just
know something which you will call in
the theory of automatic control to a
sampling sampling
interval so we know that they are one
hour one hour
apart
um when we know the time stamp so when
something something happened we can we
can uh reason about about this uh I
remember uh some uh Rous data from from
slna which were 15 15 minute uh data so
every 15 minutes there was a there was a
one one data point
and and suddenly the the data points uh
started to to double so there were like
one two 3 four and there was one two
three four there were like like uh for
one hour in some in some period there
was like double amount of the of the
data if I say this and I'm not not sure
whether whether I was whether I
Illustrated it it well uh what would you
think can can cause this
basically it was saying that for one
hour the sensor was uh was giving us two
different
values how can that
happen what are you whispering to Adam
okay the question is
um I'm just I'm just now now trying
trying to reframe it in the in the form
of a of a logical puzzles like uh the
twins uh were born but they are two days
uh older or uh two there there is two
day difference in their birthdays how
can how is that possible you know this
this sort of puzzles or or
riddles okay I wasn't wasn't
illustrative illustrative uh enough uh
the the the problem uh which uh you may
encounter with with with this which
which we encountered is just the
curiosity is the uh the daylight saving
shift yeah summertime winter time so at
at some some point some point in time
the the database it was recording like
uh when do we sh shift the time it's
like 2 2 a.m. 3 3: a.m. so it was 2:
a.m. 2 2:15 a.m. 2:30 a.m. 2:45 a.m.
3:00 a.m. 2 a.m. because the because the
the time shifted and now I don't know
which direction is that whether it's the
winter to summer or summer to Summer to
Winter yeah so there are there are some
uh some possible possible challenges
that uh that you might you might uh
encounter um it's also uh well hard to
hard to obser observe the the the the
correlations uh well let's go back to
our oh there to to to these examples
yeah these these are the two time series
time series plots and simple example
because we have only only two two two
variables and uh still it might be it
might be quite quite hard to uh to
observe that there is there is some
correlation if something happens then
something something uh reacts uh to it
there is no that's if there is uh if
there is no no cases and and so
on okay uh so with this uh Scatter Plots
or correlation plots uh can can help us
let's try this is very similar to that
example with the with the power plants
but uh now we are now we just uh took
two variables and uh we don't know we
are now losing the sense of time yeah
the we don't know when these uh these
data points were collected what we can
say is uh if we have one one variable we
we uh plot its value we have also a
corres oning corresponding pair which
were happening at the at the same time
or doesn't need to be at the same time I
don't want to complicate it but uh
whatever whatever we we know at least we
know when when they are when they are
happening uh what would you say about uh
about these two these two variables what
would you guess what would you conclude
there some
cor there is some correlation and the
correlation is positive or
negative I'm sure if I answered
correctly you you you answered correctly
uh you you would have guessed that that
there there that there is a
h mhm yes what what does what does it
mean yeah so explain why you why you
would think this is a positive
correlation
one
pair to be for example
the AIS
mhm uh
one the Y AIS is the function of the one
of the XIs so we can see that we somehow
just try to approximate it with for
example with our
curve or
line
the slope of
it the positive M it's a it's positive
slope or you you might uh you might uh
say the same same things in in a in a
different words like okay it it appears
well there is some some sort of a some
sort of a mean a very common common
situation and uh if the variable which
is plotted on the horizontal axis is
increasing what will the other variable
do the other variable it seems that if
if we move to the right then we are also
Al moving up which means that if this
variable increases then also this one
increases yeah the the case of the of
the Germany was actually an example of a
negative correlation if for example here
we have some nominal some mean mean case
so if we are generating more power then
we are emitting less
CO2 uh another interesting observation
here is uh that it's uh seems to be
quite likely it's quite probable for
these two variables to actually yeah
have a certain certain value
certain very frequently appearing uh
appearing combination and this plot is
already already done in a such way we
will call it centering that we will
remove uh these uh the values so we
actually would like take the take the
the axis and move the origin into the
into the place where where this most
common value the mean uh is uh is is is
taking place why is it because then we
can even even easier can can see the
positive correlations right if I if I uh
increase the value on the horizontal
axis by two then the value on the
vertical axis is is increasing
increasing by by 10 yeah it's much
harder sorry much much harder to to
observe uh in in these absolute absolute
numbers yeah what does it mean 600 uh
gam CO2 equivalent what and what does it
mean is it is it big is it small here we
can sorry here we here we can direct
directly directly see okay this uh this
uh these points here would uh represent
positive deviation from the from the
mean and these points here would would
represent negative deviation because
their values are actually actually
negative so it's not only visualization
in terms of how do I plot the graph also
how do I how do I um transform my my
variables we have already seen the the
logarithmic example with the with the
Bitcoin price um
um okay we have seen this another
interesting one which is already kind of
suggested in in in this this plot with
the with the with the colors is uh are
the are the histograms histograms you
know you you've seen right it's a when
we are when we are trying to show what
when we are trying to represent that uh
there is some dense
in certain regions certain parts of the
of the of the data so here we are
representing that uh there is a certain
uh similar values in the region which is
now plotted in in red don't know how
much visible is that but for example the
blue color is now representing here an
interesting thing uh it actually
represents all the points with a certain
distance from the from the mean so it's
trying to uh show us well either
outliers or some values that are much
less likely yeah also for the for the
Germany it's much less likely to uh
produce uh produce this amount of
electricity with with this uh CO2
intensity emission it's much more likely
to be somewhere in this in this uh In
This Cloud we can also see it in for
example in Poland these points are much
much less less likely here it's much
denser and we
can uh we can uh visualize it with this
kind of a this kind of a histograms so
this is a split between this is a
scatter or correlation plot which on its
own is showing uh actually almost almost
no no correlation between the data why
would it be almost no no correlation
well uh we cannot really say let's let's
do let's do the test from from before if
we increase slightly this this variable
then what what will happen most likely
in the in the previous example yeah if
we increase the variable we Inc increase
the value of the horizontal variable
then then we we would we would see that
also the values of the of the vertical
variable increase
here we cannot really say that yeah
there are many increasing many
increasing no don't don't okay I thought
thought you were you are getting lost um
about the the density of the of the
points here come here come the the
histograms so histograms in the in the
vertical variable histogram in the in
the horizontal variable what are they
trying to trying to represent well
basically histogram is trying to make
sort of bins it's really like a like a
basket where we say okay in this in this
Basket in the in the middle all the Val
all the uh values
between I don't know minus
0.1 until until plus 0.1 will fall so
give me a count how many many dots we
can we can see with with this with this
value and this count is really like
throwing a Pebble Stone some some ball
in the uh in a in a column yeah so there
we there we get this uh this uh this
representation where we can directly see
some values are totally unlikely some
values we didn't observe Never Never
Happened some values are are more likely
and uh maybe this starts to uh look like
the famous uh bell curve like the
gausian gaan curve which I hope uh you
either saw this one is a is a very very
nice example of uh of that of that curve
curve so either I hope do you saw it or
you will or you will at least refresh
your your memories about
it okay let's get uh well we can have
several different uh combinations uh of
the scatter plot so we have the the
values of these uh of the two variables
again again ploted uh with a similar
visualization about the density of the
of the of the point so red means that
there is a very likely place for
something to be
happening
um which brings me to the last one the
the par plots this is maybe the the less
less likely I don't know whether whether
you've uh you've seen the the parity
plots but they are quite uh quite useful
because uh what we uh what we talk uh
talk be before what we talk about before
all these all these plots uh they have a
they have a slight slight problem that
uh I need to need to decide about the
number of variables that I will that I
will plot yeah I here here there are two
variables represented with some sort of
the number uh or the or the frequency of
the of the values I I now plotted three
dimensions I cannot I hardly can can
plot can plot more so I always need to
need to need to choose for for the
relatively small small number of
variables that that I can visually
visually represent of course I can have
more more pictures but that is also also
quite uh quite limited um so uh one
thing is to uh have like uh one one one
possibility is to actually uh plot the
trend which I observed versus how my my
my model how my understanding of the of
the data is predicting predicting the
trend and uh this is what in principle
parity parity plots plots do uh this is
a specific example uh of it I'll I'll
I'll try to try to decrypt it it's
actually uh
brightness of uh pixels in uh in two
photographs that were taking that that
were taken just uh uh 4 hours apart so
there is a there is a brightness of the
photo in in in the numbers between zero
and and 0.5 so whether it's white or or
whe whether it's whether it's uh whether
there is a black color on the on the
photo and of course the the the same
same thing is here so we are trying to
plot the two two two variables which
actually there share the unit but one is
uh actual observation and and other
might be a either a prediction of that
variable or it might be a variable that
we are again trying to trying to get
some get some correlation with um now we
also have some sort of a histogram so uh
the blue dots is where uh where the some
value some brightness of a pixel was
observed but it's not that likely on on
the on the other hand the the red one uh
is where we have many data many pixels
and if you are asking where is the red
one the red one is is around here uh and
this this shows so two photographs of
the same object maybe if I if I took a
photo photo of you in the beginning of
lecture and and at the end of the of the
lecture it would show what uh there is a
there are white walls and lot of lot of
white color in in the photo so that
would be that would be represented here
and basically along along this line Y =
X I can now try to see uh what are the
similarities between the photo because
if the if uh if I have a brightness 0.1
whatever whatever that that means in one
pixel then if I have the if I took a
photo of the of the same situation then
uh I would be this point would be lying
around around this line uh basically
what this plot is trying to trying to
show that these two photos are very very
similar and it's just just some noise or
some little things that changed on the
on the photo that they are different in
between them you will do some
experiments with the with the parity
plots during the during the
exercises okay this one I'm not going to
to talk about today uh I will just uh
finish it now ask you for any questions
that you might have
comments or
anything and if it's not the case I
would like you to uh say your opinion
about how did you like the like the
lecture how do you like that I I'm I'm
speaking in English whether do you
understand it um in the YouTube video
postprocess after the lecture you will
see the subtitles you can even download
the transcript R if you if you want from
from the lecture
and and which which can help you that
way